I'm Laura Ingram this is the Ingram
angle from Washington tonight
don't take the bait that's the focus of
tonight's angle
oh the left is so upset that there
weren't riots in Manhattan when Trump
came to get booked by Alvin Bragg's
persecution Squad now they were
desperate for January 6th style images
but the only problems were at the hands
of Mast antifa freaks who were trying to
start trouble
now in this clip one is playing the role
of kind of an evil Mary Poppins
character so brave that they're all
still hiding behind masks Central
casting for morons
I am here with some antifa members I'm
trying to report I now have this um
person who is blocking me I have these
guys as well here who are trying to
intimidate me I don't appreciate it very
much and uh they they told me that I
need to get the S out
[Music]
here
they're also all very attractive are
they not
but it's a terrible precedent and bad
for the country that these politically
motivated Trump investigations are going
to go forward no matter how outraged any
of us are of course the angle will not
shy away from covering this and we will
offer legal analysis that you won't see
anywhere else
but to really understand what the next
18 months are going to be like
politically
you have to stay focused on a few key
points first
in 2020 Joe Biden won with only 306
electoral votes
so if he had lost Pennsylvania Georgia
and Arizona for example president Trump
would have been re-elected
second in 2020 Biden received 51.3
percent of the popular vote
as of today 538 summary of the polls
shows that Biden's approval rating is
only 43 percent
and according to Real Clear Politics
Biden's average approval rating on the
economy is only 37.1 percent
third
there is no reason to believe that the
economic situation for any of us is
going to improve significantly between
now and the election if anything things
are going to get worse layoffs have
started for instance in Tech and Beyond
last month the FED projected that the
United States real GDP would grow by an
anemic point four percent and in 2023 uh
only 1.2 percent and 2024 things are
just as bad now no wonder Democrats are
hoping that Trump's legal woes will
drown out this other news
these hideously bad economic numbers
mean that many voters are looking at a
very Grim economic future and Biden
supporters in the big cities they're not
immune from these problems according to
the U.S census between July 21 and July
2022 L.A County lost 91 000 people Cook
County Illinois home to Chicago lost 68
000 people in the same period
still in its Mayoral race yesterday
Chicagoans voted once again for Decline
and despair
meet mayor-elect Brandon Johnson whose
crime fighting strategy consists of
abolishing the police
you said she was dead that was her
sister the Wicked Witch of the East the
Wicked Witch of the West
is worse than the
who killed The Witch of the East or the
fuel no no it was an accident I didn't
mean to kill anybody
yeah he's worse than the other one uh
he's worse than Lightfoot apparently
Chicago has not suffered enough
or they took those let's go Brandon
chance literally in any case how could
the Dems have won with their track
record
people are not feeling any safer
communities have not transformed by
putting more money into police I'm
absolutely confident
um that we will be the generation that
will respond react to the global
movement that has called them for
redirecting money away from policing and
militarized police forces
well I guess voters in these big cities
aren't moved on the issue of crime
there's no other explanation
for example in Chicago 21 people were
shot and four died over the weekend
or consider what happened in San
Francisco last night where a 43 year old
Tech CEO was stabbed to death in an
upscale neighborhood
or in D.C just two days ago when a 31
year old woman was murdered by someone
who was released by a Biden appointed
judge after multiple criminal arrests
nothing right now is going right for
Biden
China has become the most powerful
country in the world while we're stuck
in what appears to be an endless
conflict in Ukraine crime is up
Americans are losing their patriotism
and their faith the military can't even
find enough volunteers to fill its ranks
by every possible measure we're headed
toward economic and geopolitical crises
the likes of which we haven't seen since
the 1970s
and the Democrats are stuck with Biden
he's literally the most popular
candidate they have
the mayors of the Twin Cities are here
as well Jacob Frye from Minneapolis
where are you Jacob
he was here I was I guess he knew I was
going to speak the progress we've made
in building an economy from the middle
out and the bottom up
because when it comes to the top down my
Dad's kitchen table not much dropped on
that kitchen table from the top down
faced with these facts Biden and his
team have no choice but to look for ways
to shift blame
and that's why you're going to see Biden
doing everything possible to offend and
anger Republican voters over the next
few months that's why they supported the
indictment of President Trump that's why
they keep threatening to ban everything
from gas stoves to gas-powered
automobiles that's why they attack
parents who complain about pornography
in schools and Why They seized upon a
horrific school shooting in Nashville to
bash social conservatives
we have seen a record number of lgbtqi
bills
anti-lgbtqi uh bills more this is a
president that has been committed to
this community that has been committed
to our to our kids in the trans
Community to trans Youth and he's going
to continue to fight for them
and that's why they won't ramp up
domestic oil and gas production
they don't really care if things get
worse in the United States things are
already so bad that Biden shouldn't be
re-elected and they aren't getting any
better in fact they'd be happy to see
things get worse if they can blame our
problems on the GOP
this ain't your father's Republican
Party
this is what I call the mega Republicans
the mega republicans in Congress
threatened undo all this progress
they're putting our economy in jeopardy
Biden would like a debt default that he
could blame on the GOP
but what he wants most of all is more
violence Another January 6 type event
one that they can blame on the
Republicans that's why the left made
such a big show out of the increased
security when President Trump went to
New York this week
they want to encourage the narrative
that GOP voters are dangerous radicals
how do you predict somebody who probably
may not have all their sanity to begin
with suddenly deciding that they've had
enough deciding that they need to lash
out at the government I think we are
going to see incidents of violence
because I see nothing from the
Republican Party leadership doing
anything to Tamp down this sort of a
grievement with local state and national
law enforcement
Peter strzok the ethics standard Bearer
for the Democrats look they want to
terrify Suburban voters in places like
Connecticut and New Jersey so that those
voters will feel like they have no
choice but to stick with old Joe and yes
old decline
now all of this is based on a lie now we
know it's a lie real danger comes from
out of touch Elites who think that there
should be one set of rules for us and a
very different and much more favorable
set of rules for them
they're the ones who've wrecked our
economy damaged our schools devastated
our cities and empowered our
geopolitical enemies that's dangerous
but none of that matters to Biden and
his supporters in the Press
they just need examples of unruly
conservatives that they can then use to
threaten their supporters in the big
cities
so here's the lesson for tonight
don't take the bait we need 270
electoral votes to change this country
if we don't get them next November we
Face four more years of Decline and
despair
we cannot get to 270 by simply carrying
the same states that President Trump won
in 2020 we need to convince millions of
Americans who voted for Biden in 2020 to
join our side
we can't do that with threats we can't
do it with anger we certainly can't do
it with civil unrest when you're
complaining you're not winning and we
want to win in 2024.
so of course we're going to keep
pointing out Biden's lives and other
unfair practices
but don't be distracted by the hateful
rhetoric of Biden and his supporters
the only way to stop the Democrats is to
beat them and the only way to beat them
is to say laser focused on the economy
on rebuilding our place in the world and
on replacing Biden's failed policies
with the same type of policies that had
this economy roaring in 2019
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else